direction blois et son quartier de la
bouillie un secteur inondable de 350
hectares aujourd'hui rendus à la nature
jadis on y trouvait pourtant un stade de
foot un vélodrome ou encore des
habitations
maintenant la d urbanisation finalisée
elle la communauté d'agglomération de
blois souhaite connaître vos attentes
sur cet espace une consultation en ligne
élancée depuis le début du mois
les explications de lucas chopin le
réaménagement de la bouillie rappelle
beaucoup de souvenirs à françois from et
maire de la commune de vineuil
il a grandi aux abords du déversoir
aussi très heureux à titre personnel
cette zone de la bouillie est bien
représenté une zone de vie quand j'étais
tout jeune qui on allait se promener
voilà on allait se promener on est là à
blois ont traversé cette zone là en vélo
la bouillie est à cheval sur les
communes de vineuil blois et saint
gervais la forêt une aubaine touristique
est naturel pour saint gervais c'est un
écrin qui fait le pendant à notre forêt
de russie qui est un également un écrin
vert et qui nous fait une continuité
paysagère environnementales écologiques
importantes sur sur le secteur
aujourd'hui et jusqu'à la fin du mois
les habitants de l'agglomération sont
invités à se prononcer sur les futurs
aménagements sur un globally ce point fr
un questionnaire à bord de tous les
aspects du secteur de la bouillie on
leur demande leur avis sur deux choses
d'abord sur l'aménagement général du
quartier de ce grand secteur de 350
hectares et puis il ya dans une deuxième
partie de ce qu'on a appelé des focus
c'est à dire des questions plus précises
sur les lieux de promenade les lieux
d'arrivée dans la ville les lieux
pédagogique
après la consultation il faudra sans
doute procéder aux dernières
expropriations avant de partir pour
plusieurs années de travaux